Close quarter combat in Ukraine.
Be a couple of weeks.
Cranes Eastern Command says down
heavy losses.
More than 200 Russians sold for hours.
Hundreds more.
Western officials say the vast manpower
and access to prison recruits
conflict with Russia's defense minister
reportedly now turning to Russia
to try to get new work.
The mounting losses are prompting
wives and mothers to stop sending.
They're equating them
to, quote, slaughter.
Joining me now is Fence and Trump
administration secretary.
I appreciate your time. So I'm here.
I know these are Russian women
loved ones were forced to
join is only four days of training
to verify these claims.
But it's very consistent videos
that we share daily.
Does Putin
any shortage of potential reporting?
I think so, Erin.
You know,
the Ministry of Defense
said that committed up
to 90% of cases in Ukraine.
Oh, you mentioned a Bogner group,
thousand soldiers
for convicts
ads and the recruiting drive.
They may have pulled in 300,
but you know what we think left.
It's it's
a really bad sit down with these
young recruits
send out much training or any equip
immoral and it's Russian
people have to get fed up
and their young men center called Ukraine
at our secretary from a Russians was
by an independent Russian journal.
It reads quote The ad out like sunflower
beware around us
there's no truth
any Whitlams to the slaughter to our
we saw corpses without arms and legs
hanging out.
What is your reaction?
You know, we're looking at print.
There's
frankly nice and neat handwriting.
Well,
it really
there and back
most reports
are that
for Ukraine
that has killed from 5 to 7 Russians.
Ukrainians report that Russia
up like you know dogs
on the
battlefield vulgar commanders
or advance will shoot you back.
I mean it is just really happening
there and situation
and the Ukrainian country
for their sovereignty
so they're fighting to win
and they are what's happening
to this generation of Russian men.
And I'm afraid
it's only going to get one point.
The Ukrainian offensive
maybe in April
and it's really going to put push that
where they're going
to have to conscript more of a of men
from their country
as within,
you know, some sort of a scene that,
you know, obviously not using.
The Institute for the Study
and Defense Minister
is, quote, likely
seizing to deliberately expand
convict Wagner
in an effort to weaken
obviously the leader of the derail
his ambitions for greater Kremlin
so based should
military is trying to get Wagner
Russians trying to get Russia battlefield
and Matt
you know
if you just take a
does this shock you at all
know something like this
well and one
but on the other it's not surprising
of course
has made an enemy of ministry of defense
giving his credit the chain of command.
Counterpart Sergei.
And he is searching for inland
and trying to work for Vladimir Putin.
Now, what's it
prigozhin is from that he's
trying to even call the Kremlin.
Right.
It's very common
within the country right now
about the young boys beings.
Fortunately, it seems that Putin,
you know, the ethnic minorities, Russia,
not not the young
or around
Moscow, out to the ethnic minorities
that make up a large portion
of the Russian,
of course, is all this happens
you get more Moscow,
the threat of some sort of nuclear risk.
You have the obviously rising tensions
with China on text.
Former President Trump again
tonight in iowa.
He just said for you
standing before me I am
the only can make
this promise will prevent will
because I really believe
when to have World War
we served under him as president.
I have World War Three number eight.
And look,
I think the Republican Party
are going to have a
of not in the Republican primary
to take on
President Trump with
them are very capable
and we need a new generation of parties.
And so one of those younger leaders
will go
and and I'm hope contest this year
very much. I appreciate your time, sir.
Thanks here.
All right.